NUNES, TREY GOWDY, OTHER MEMBERS
HAVE CONSTITUTIONAL OVERSIGHT
AUTHORITY.
JOINING US NOW FORMER U.S.
ATTORNEY FOR THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA, JOE DID YOU KNOW BOB
ALAN DERSHOWITZ, GOOD TO SEE YOU
ALAN DERSHOWITZ, GOOD TO SEE YO
YOU.
YOU'VE HAD A BUSY 36 HOURS.
YESTERDAY.
I REALLY WANT YOUR TAKE ONE AND
FBI DIRECTOR COMPARES A SITTING
PRESIDENT TO A MOB BOSS.
>> IT PROVES THE POINT OF MY
BOOK "TRUMPED UP."
YOU CAN FIND EVIDENCE TO CREATE
OR MANUFACTURE CRIMES THAT GIVES
ANYBODY, IF YOU'RE DETERMINED TO
DO IT.
THAT'S WHAT'S WRONG WITH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THEY COME IN WITH TARGETS
PAINTED ON PEOPLE'S BACK.
PEOPLE LIKE COMEY AND MUELLER
ARE GOING TO FIND CRIMES.
WHETHER THEY HAVE TO GO AND TRY
TO FIND A TECHNICAL VIOLATION,
BANKING LAWS UPON WHICH THEY CAN
HOOK PORNOGRAPHY STARS OR THINGS
OF THAT KIND.
EVEN YOUR ACCOUNT WHICH WAS
METAPHORICAL IN PART, PROVES
AGAIN IF YOU ARE DETERMINED TO
FIND CRIMES AGAINST EVERYBODY,
YOU CAN DO IT.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO RESTRICT
AND LIMIT THE APPLICATION OF THE
CRIMINAL LAW TO CLEAR,
UNEQUIVOCAL CRIMES AND DON'T USE
IT AGAINST POLITICAL ENEMIES
UNLESS THE EVIDENCE IS
OVERWHELMING.
>> Sean: JOE DiGENOVA.
>> IT'S CLEAR THAT NO MATTER
WHAT JAMES COMEY SAYS ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WHICH ARE DISGRACEFUL COMMENTS
BY A FORMER FBI DIRECTOR, AND HE
HAS BESMIRCHED FOREVER HIS TERM
AS FBI DIRECTOR, WHAT WE KNOW IS
JAMES COMEY IS A DIRTY COP.
HE'S A COMPLETELY DIRTY COP.
COMPROMISE FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THE INVESTIGATION
INTO HILLARY CLINTON.
IT IS ALSO VERY CLEAR THAT ROD
ROSENSTEIN IS SO INCOMPETENT,
COMPROMISE, AND CONFLICTED THAT
HE CAN NO LONGER SERVE AS THE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL.
JEFF SESSIONS NOW HAS AN
OBLIGATION TO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES TO FIRE ROD
ROSENSTEIN AFTER ROSENSTEIN
AUTHORIZED THE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
AND UNPROFESSIONAL SEARCH OF THE
OFFICE OF MICHAEL COHEN IN
NEW YORK.
JEFF SESSIONS TOMORROW MORNING
SHOULD FIRE ROD ROSENSTEIN.
IT'S NOT UP TO THE PRESIDENT TO
FIRE MR. ROSENSTEIN.
IT'S MR. SESSIONS' JOB AND HE
HAS A DUTY TO FIRE ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
>> Sean: PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ,
YOU HAD SAID THAT THE RAID ON
MICHAEL COHEN'S HOTEL ROOM, HIS
HOME AND OFFICE WAS A VIOLATION
OF HIS CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
DO YOU AGREE WITH JOE THAT IT'S
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL JOB TO STEP
IN AND FIRE ROD ROSENSTEIN?
>> I WOULD DO IT DIFFERENTLY.
I THINK ROD ROSENSTEIN IS
RECUSED.
HE CAN'T SERVE ON AN
INVESTIGATION IN WHICH SHE WILL
END UP BEING THE KEY WITNESS.
IF I WERE A LAWYER FOR
DONALD TRUMP, AND I AM NOT, I AM
JUST SAYING WHAT I WOULD SAY
ABOUT ANYBODY, I WOULD BE MAKING
A MOTION IN FRONT OF A JUDGE.
FIRST AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
RECUSED ROSENSTEIN.
THEN IN FRONT OF A JUDGE.
YOU CANNOT BE A WITNESS IN THE
SAME CASE.
THE THING TO ME THAT'S MOST
DISTURBING TONIGHT, I AM A
LIFELONG MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN
CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION.
I WAS ON THE NATIONAL BOARD OF
THE AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION.
TODAY THE AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION WENT OUT OF ITS
WAY TO JUSTIFY AND DEFEND THE
RAID ON THE LAWYER'S OFFICE.
RISKS THAT IT DOES TO
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS.
MOST OF YOUR VIEWERS DON'T KNOW
HOW TAGUE TEAMS WORK.
>> Sean: THEY TAKE THIS
INFORMATION.
>> INCLUDING THE MATERIAL
ULTIMATELY FOUND TO BE
CONFIDENTIAL.
AND THEN SOMEBODY IN THE
GOVERNMENT READS THE MATERIAL,
INCLUDING THE MATERIAL THAT'S
CONFIDENTIAL, AND THEN THE
PERSON SAYS THIS MATERIAL IS
CONFIDENTIAL.
ALTHOUGH I HAVE READ IT.
I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE IT TO THE
PROSECUTOR.
I'M NEVER GOING TO TELL ANYBODY
ABOUT IT.
THEN SUDDENLY IT LEAKS.
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
WE KNOW THEY RAIDED THE OFFICE
TO LOOK AT THE STUFF ABOUT THE
ACCESS HOLLYWOOD TAPE.
I CAN IMAGINE THE CONVERSATION
BETWEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP, THEN
CANDIDATE TRUMP COME AND HIS
LAWYER MICHAEL COHEN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS THAT WAS AN
ILLEGAL TAPE.
DIDN'T KNOW THE MICROPHONE WAS
ON.
IS THERE ANYTHING WE CAN DO FROM
STOP COMING OUT LAWFULLY BECAUSE
IT WAS ILLEGALLY OBTAINED?
THEN THE GOVERNMENT GETS THAT
CONVERSATION.
>> Sean: DOES THIS HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH RUSSIA?
SERIOUSLY.
YOU ARE LAUGHING BECAUSE IT'S SO
ABSURD.
JOE, WE HAVE SO MUCH TO GET TO.
WE WILL CARRY YOU OVER FOR THE
NEXT SEGMENT.
I WANT YOU TO WEIGH IN ON THE
ASPECTS OF THIS.
THE PERSON WHO HAS
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE, IT
WOULD BE THE PRESIDENT'S RIGHT
TO INVOKE, NOT MICHAEL COHEN.
>> I MUST TELL YOU I FIND THIS
RAID OF MR. COMEY'S   -- MR. COH
RAID OF MR. COMEY'S   -- MR. CON
RAID OF MR. COMEY'S   -- MR. COS
OFFICE.
WHAT ROD ROSENSTEIN AND BOB
MUELLER HAVE DONE IS WEAPONIZE
IN AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL WAY THE
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION PROCESS
WHICH SHOULD BE SACROSANCT.
BUT THEY HAVE DONE IS THEY HAVE
CONDUCTED AND ARE CONDUCTING
SOMETHING THAT'S CALLED AN
INTERIM GRAND JURY.
THEY ARE USING A GRAND JURY TO
TERRORIZE PEOPLE.
THAT'S AN ABUSE OF POWER.
MR. ROSENSTEIN IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR IT.
WHILE I AGREE WITH ALAN
DERSHOWITZ WHOLEHEARTEDLY THAT
MR. ROSENSTEIN CAN'T POSSIBLY
ETHICALLY PARTICIPATE IN THIS,
IT WILL MAKE NO DIFFERENCE TO
HIM BECAUSE HE NOW HAS AN ANIMUS
TOWARDS THE PRESIDENT OF THE